Okay, so our program is lacking just one more
thing. Let's say that we want to take a break
after every two hours of work on the computer.
I can increase the duration of delay from ten seconds
to two hours. Now remember, the sleep function takes
in seconds, so this number to the computer is two
seconds and not two hours. To fix this, I
can find out the number of seconds in two hours.
And use that instead. Since I'm still testing my program,
I will keep the wait time to a manageable ten seconds.
Okay, so now that we have written our first program,
let's understand where functions like
webbrowser.open and time.sleep are coming from.